Lawrence Krauss is a world-renowned
theoretical physicist a man who
significantly changed our view and our
understanding of the cosmos he's a
fierce advocate for the public
understanding of Science and aims to
bring it closer to the masses through
the origins podcast recently he's also
been pushing for much needed societal
and cultural changes Lawrence's books
have been pivotal in popularizing
science and have profoundly impacted me
since I first read them and his latest
book is no exception check out my
episode from earlier this year right
here join us as we embark on a
captivating Journey to the edge of
knowledge recorded live in October 2023
at the San Diego Aaron Space Museum so
this is actually from an 11-year-old who
asked a good question are any of the
meteorites you handed out
radioactive and do you know have any
thoughts about that uh so meteorite
radioactivity well what's interesting
about it is that they were sort of
formed thanks to a nuclear processes a
radioactive process well not radioactive
but nuclear processes that when a star
of a certain size a certain girth uh
gets to the end of its lifetime it no
longer can support its massive body that
it's built up over billions of years and
something called a type two Supernova
occurs where the material that makes up
the outer lay layers no longer is
supported by the pressure the weight of
the outer material is no longer
supported by the heat the heat pressure
keeping the nuclear fires going that
happens when it makes iron when the star
makes fuses two lighter nuclei together
to make iron silicon I say or silicon
oxygen you make iron 56 and that is no
longer exothermic doesn't give off
energy and then the star collapses and
then explodes back in the most luminous
explosions since the big bang and these
could be seen from across the entire uh
Universe essentially so this material is
billions of years old because it's a
material that was made the last thing
the star ever did it's like what's the
last thing that goes through a fly's ey
before it dies on your windshield it's
but get it okay anyway uh this material
is mostly iron so it's not radioactive
and it is uh it is a pristine material
that shares something in common with
your blood because the iron in your
blood came from the same Supernova
process that produces these iron
meteorites so this stuff is magnetic it
is not radioactive and you should play
around with it if you are so inclined
and you will not get endangered I my
word is a do I'm a doctor also so well
let me let me let me make a slight
correction there everything is
radioactive uh and I I think and and so
there's radioactivity coming from your
big toe um small amounts of it Trace
Amounts of radioactivity everywhere one
of the big problems in making particle
physics exp new experiments to look at
things like dark matter is to get rid of
of the radioactivity it's really hard
because we're looking for events that
are so so rare that if there's a little
bit of radioactivity in this big tank
then it'll overwhelm the thing we're
looking for so even even if um and I
think I once a book I wrote again well
in fact we were looking for things in
Dark Matter detectors were looking for
events that are a bet about a million
times smaller in rate than the
radioactivity in your big toe and so
there's a little a little bit of rad
activity and everything and that's okay
um even it's just impurities it depends
on on things and and
so you
know and there's also stuff coming from
up there cosmic ray so I I have a little
gger C I like to take with me around
places to see when I was up at Greenland
looking and stuff but anyway so there's
a little bit of radio activity but
nothing but the but this is iron which
in general is not a radioa the dominant
stuff here is the is the is iron which
is the which is the most stable in some
ways the most stable of the heavy
elements at all okay this one we can
both answer too I
think maybe I'll start Brendan asks if
aliens were to exist how much more
intelligent than us would they be or
could they reach us even with less
intelligence the the answer to the first
question is we don't know we have no
idea if they exist whether they're more
intelligent or less intelligent or
intelligent if they're far less
intelligent we have much less likelihood
of finding out about them because the
way that other aliens would find out
about us and why most of the universe
doesn't know we exist is they'd look for
the is they'd look for the radio
Transmissions that we've emitted and
we've only been doing that for 10050
years and that means since it travel the
speed light if you're more than 15 light
years away from us which is most of the
Galaxy you know there's nothing special
about the Earth Earth so we might learn
about other kinds of life but
intelligent life we' require to be at
least technological at least as
technological as us now one might say
and I'm going to only talk a little bit
because you can add one of the things
we'd say is look our sun is only four
and a half billion years old our GA our
our Earth is 4 and a half billion years
old our solar system and the Galaxy is
about 12 billion years old so you might
say that most most stars are a lot older
than our are son and a lot of them are
um and therefore civilizations could be
billions of years older than us and
that's true maybe but the problem is in
order to have the
iron that Brian was just talking about
stars have to explode in order to have
all the materials that make up the Earth
Stars had to explode and it takes time
and so it it in the early history of our
galaxy there wasn't there weren many
heavy elements that would make up rocky
planets it takes time you you can argue
that most of the atoms in your body went
through maybe 10 different Stellar
explosions before the one that may have
produced us now and that takes time so
it could be that there aren't many more
civilizations that are you know as old
as us because it took four billion years
for intelligence to arise on Earth and
so we but the neat thing is we don't
know and in a situation like that the
only way to find out is to look and let
the universe tell us and if we don't as
Carl San would say absence of evidence
is not evidence of absence just means
you have to build a better experiment
and Ryan knows all about that you not
seeing something often means you just
have to do a better job and and
Technology improves at a great rate so
you can anyway you can add to that yeah
I mean I would just say if you plotted
the history of the universe if you
plotted intelligence even on Earth there
was a long maybe dominant portion of
Earth's history when Dolphins were more
intelligent than the the Nissin and
strop and all all sorts of other things
or their predecessors maybe because
they've been around longer than than
human beings or Homo sapian Sapien have
been around for so the question is not
maybe more in or less intelligent but
technological because no matter what the
Dolphins can keep evolving but you're
not going to do you know build a falcon
heavy underwater you have to do meler
you're not have technology without the
opposable thumbs that we have so they
may be even more intelligent things than
us in the universe although there's zero
evidence for that I think it's best
thing we can say we don't know um but
these things that manipulate space and
time to get here uh they are subject to
the fundamental laws of physics
thermodynamics Etc which we have great
confidence will never be overturned but
I think there is a fallacy that because
there's so many stars out there you and
I have talked about this there has to be
life and I told you and you've been to
Antarctica or Canada I don't know which
one is colder uh you're from Canada uh
but uh but I've been there there's very
little life there so if you were to S
there's a lot of leg stream but what
we've learned is it is there life that
extreme environments you'd never imagine
to be life in acid in boiling water and
cola life seems to be able to fill every
Niche that's possible so in fact I
suspect strongly now this is an
intelligent life that there's that
there's um microbial life elsewhere in
our solar system I would be surprised if
underneath the oceans of Eur of Europa
or Enceladus we didn't find evidence of
microbial life and and it would be very
fascinating and and we could talk about
that we don't talk see if he's right in
five more but uh go ahead yeah we'll
we'll find it I will say as a pessimist
which I am in general my late friend
who's a a writer named cor McCarthy was
a very um wrote very dark books that
some of you may have read or seen movies
based on his book when I first met him
he's a very cheerful guy and I asked him
how he could be so cheerful and he said
I'm a pessimist but that's no reason to
be gloomy anyway um this is a quick
question but I I we have to answer
because it comes from a nine-year-old
who I know Arie and it's said how did
you know that the card I was thinking of
was the six's Spades and the answer is I
tricked you
okay um Angela asks oh this is a this is
well this is probably a question for me
but um is dark energy potential energy
or kinetic energy if it's one of the two
how is it measured that's a that's a
really good question energy if you if
you took High School physics energy
comes at in a bunch of different forms
that one form is the energy of motion
you know if I throw a ball at you and it
hits you it's got energy and it can do
work on you knock you over that comes
from kinetic energy if I lift the ball
up in the air it's got the potential to
do work if I Let It Go by Falling on you
that's potential energy and if you were
going to say that dark energy is more
potential energy it's not due to motion
in fact there's nothing to move that's
the weird thing it's the energy of empty
space so there's nothing there to move
so it's potential energy but how it's
measured um well they're different ways
ways and and we're looking and one of
the things you know Simons might do will
may help on that the way it was first
discovered was the fact that dark energy
as I said is gravitationally repulsive
and it causes the universe to expand
ever faster and by looking at distant
objects and seeing how they're how fast
they're moving away from me us as a
function of their distance and therefore
the time we look back in the history of
the universe because it takes light find
out time to get to us we can map out the
expansion rate of the universe and
discovered to the surprise of The
Observers that the universe is speeding
up and the amount by which it speeds up
is directly related to the amount of
dark energy there is and and that's
that's the first way to measure it there
are other ways and one of the other ways
is to again always looking at the
history of the universe kind of doing
doing AR Universal archaeology which is
really kind of what Brian does is to
look state by state and and try and look
at how individ ual objects are evolving
like galaxies and all of those things
depend on the expansion rate of the
universe so lots of different
measurements are trying to be performed
to see if that dark energy is really
constant which I'm convinced it is but
but we'll need experiments to see do you
want to add anything into that okay
here's one we could both talk about
although we well anyway I'm not sure we
have much to say but how advanced is AI
versus what is used by the public I I
think you're meaning how advanced is are
there secret AIS that are much more
advanced than they're used by the public
I actually don't think so um I mean
because the AI systems are are really
produced by companies that are hoping to
make money and um and so they're using
they they require a lot of money and
they have to use the publicly available
information they mine the internet to
try and figure out to predict what the
next word you're going to say is or the
next word they should say to you that's
all they do is they just try and predict
the probability of the next word at
least the AI that you're that that most
of you are familiar with trap GPI and
it's pretty basic although it's quite
amazing what it can do and um and in
fact I don't know what it's okay to said
Brian when I talked to him earlier by
email about what he was going to ask me
he asked chat PPT the questions he
should ask me and I said I didn't think
they were as good as the questions we
could come up with but they're still
pretty good yeah I on my website I put
um I made a bride bot I took all every
all of my books all of my podcasts
transcript solo episodes with you me Joe
Rogan every and I put it all into there
and now I no longer have to tell my kids
bedtime story so I would go home check
in in a few minutes no but uh one thing
that they are doing that we don't really
do we meaning normal people uh coders
and and people actually doing
sophisticated uh you know software
engineering computer science so they are
using you know they are extracting more
information I think than I do when I ask
it you know what are the you know top 10
reasons that you should become a
cosmologist or or so forth or the
questions asked renowned physicist
Lawrence Krauss I find it very enjoyable
I think it's really fun and and useful
but I'm worried that they're actually
going to get dumber with time and this
the phenomena we observe in high
performance Computing the better the
computers get due to Mo's law the more
people want to use those really powerful
computers and that saps their efficiency
at putting out new data analysis new
papers and so forth what's happening
with AI until just a week or two ago
chat jpt wasn't trained on the internet
before 2021 and I always see why not
2021 that's when gpt1 came out so now
they're actually training the these are
crawling the web and they're processing
things written by AIS and that that's
kind of going to bring up maybe kind of
like what happened with mad cow disease
except mad bot disease they're going to
start to really get kind of
hallucinogenic and it could be uh reduce
their efficacy so we'll see what happens
yeah and I will say to to promote I'm
not sure when it's going to come out but
I recorded a a really fascinating
episode with one of the most remarkable
computer scientists I know a theoretical
computer scientist named Scott arenson
and um and he's now got interested in AI
safety and and doing some really neat
things and we talked about it so it'll
come out in the next month or two he's a
really neat guy really deep a very deep
thinker I'm very impressed with him I
have a special favor to ask you YouTube
analytics tells me that of the 30,000
plus of you that viewed my previous chat
with Lawrence for his book The Edge of
knowledge only onethird of the viewers
actually subscrib to the
channel I'd really appreciate it if you
consider subscribing to this channel
doing so helps me get great guests and
helps me deliver the great content that
you've come to expect from this channel
thanks so much for helping me help you
now back to my live chat with Lawrence
Krauss Kim says I read somewhere that
quantum entanglement could be key to
teleportation what are your thoughts on
that do you see this becoming a reality
has it already and I just missed it uh
that's kind of a start to question you
know I remember when I first heard about
quantum
teleportation I mean it was brilliant it
was brilliant marketing of the of the
physicist today because every journalist
in the world would then well a lot of
time called me because of the Star Trek
book but but the quantum teleportation
and teleportation are two very different
things in fact the fact that we can do
quantum teleportation
is the very same reason that we can't do
people
teleportation okay quantum mechanical
systems are very very special it takes a
lot of work to observe quantum
mechanical properties you have to very
carefully prepare systems very very
carefully experimentalists have to do a
lot of work which is why they won the
Nobel Prize last year for for the work
they're doing to to isolate the quantum
properties the weird qual properties of
quantum systems and they're weird
because we don't see them and one of the
reasons we don't see them is we're not
isolated systems I'm interacting with
you and the light in this room and all
the particles my body are interacting we
are the worst possible we're not in a in
a in a in a nice simple quantum
mechanical state so for certain very
simple quantum mechanical systems we can
do something that looks like
teleportation like we affect we measure
the properties of a particle here it
instantaneously affects the properties
that you will measure of a particle over
there it sounds like information is
being processed faster than light that's
not true it just happen there's nothing
there's no message you could ever send
from here to there that would be faster
than light but it's only possible
because it's a very very carefully
prepared system and you don't allow it
to interact with the environment all the
way in between and so we are not
carefully prepared quantum mechanical
systems so we are not going to be
teleported and it's not going to happen
and as much as I'd like it to happen and
I especially as I'm on planes a lot I
love to be able to be teleported but
it's not going to happen do you have
anything else to say about no just that
we wouldn't know if you were actually
from the future uh teleporting back in
in the past just to play trick on Kim
which we pre-prepared that Quantum
question I'm just K nothing else to add
let's see the next
one I okay I'm not going to talk about
Time time travel I did the other day so
um this is one I think you can well
we'll both answer but I think you could
probably address it interestingly enough
given you just mentioned the Simon say
it's $100 million it happens to be
funded by individuals but as well as the
government but anyway the question is
how should one respond to inquiries
about why the public should fund costly
physics
experiments well I mean I think one
statistic that you know GPT told me and
I assume it's true is that the budget
for NASA is less than what you ladies
and maybe a few gentlemen spend on
lipstick every year uh it's a very small
portion and people are confused by that
because they see all the Great Things N
look at the Moon you we've been on there
there's other massive things the Apollo
thing you guys were in for the viip
earlier um so it seems like this huge
you know they must be costing a
tremendous amount that's actually quite
small and increasingly more and more are
private individuals and Foundations
coming up with large shares of it that
then become partners with the government
to reduce the government's risk but take
advantage of the agility of a private
foundation and the risk you know
tolerance that they might have compared
to a government panel where we literally
will have you know 30 people reviewing
in for for 10 or 15 years and rightfully
so but I guess the main thing that
scientists could do is share their you
know the one place that we you know we
differ maybe is that I I believe that we
actually should require some amount of
training Outreach um you know how to
communicate with the public both for the
benefit of the public who will learn
more about science but for science
itself because if science hoers
themselves we cler ourselves in our
Ivory Towers uh doing special things
with specialized people and specialized
tools
the public you guys are going to lose
interest and say what the hell I mean if
I work I to work in a in a kitchen in a
um in a American restaurant you know
style restaurant New York State and if
my boss came in he said what are you
doing I said listen boss can't
understand what I'm doing what I'm doing
is so specialized so intense so
intelligent they would say you're out of
here we don't need you anymore you're
arrogant and I think science of the
whole does this and the excuse is always
I'm not good at it well I'm sorry
Lawrence but you weren't born knowing
Quantum electrodynamics you had to learn
that from your teacher Fineman and from
other people you put effort into things
that you deem worthy and valuable and I
think we need to teach students at a
young age there are college students and
high school students here make a YouTube
video do something it'll redown to your
benefit in ways your future self will
thank you public will thank you science
will thank you well you know I don't
disagree with you in the way you think
because um I don't think they should be
required but I think what we need to do
is include
communication in the training of
scientists more and it's and and for
many reasons not
least first of all most students who are
taking classes in science aren't going
to become
scientists but you know I spent a lot of
time when I at case which is largely an
engineering school talking to engineers
and the engineers who succeeded are the
ones who could communicate best in their
company and so I was once many years ago
MIT asked me to be on Advisory Board and
interestingly enough the idea was to
include writing in the science courses
because at MIT they all had to take a
writing class but was from some writing
instructor that none of them had any any
respect for but if the professors that
they had respect for required them to
write in the class then they'd spend
time doing it and and I think you're
right it's a a skill that's important
for anyone and it's it if if we train
more students to do it in fact when I
was a graduate student I never once I
was amazed all the time I was a graduate
student do my PhD at MIT never once was
asked to give a a presentation I the
first one I gave was after I got the job
at Harvard and I was down at Princeton
it was really it was really amazing to
me so I think it would be a a a good
thing but but regarding the cost I I do
want to take a little time because they
don't cost much that's the
point $100 million is in in in the
scheme of things is not much even 10
billion the large Adon collider or the
Hubble Space scope spent over 20
years is less than the cost of a of a
sophisticated certainly much less than
the cost of an aircraft carrier it's
like the cost the Xerox costs of the
defense department maybe are 10 times as
big and so um so it's really not much
and and and therefore you have to ask
yourself are we so poor as a society
that we can't do that and my favorite
Line This was comes from Robert Wilson
who was the first director of the fairy
National accelerator Laboratory and when
it was being built he he testified for
Congress and they asked him if it would
Aid in the defense of the nation and he
said no but it'll help keep the nation
worth
defending and I think that's really
important because if we are so poor that
we can't we have to stop asking
questions about the universe which is
one of the driving things that keeps
humans human then we might as well just
give up anyway okay Mario ask for both
gentlemen what is your opinion on how
the government is handling the UFO
situation do you believe the videos are
solid proof um I'll start you can no
videos are not solid proof I can give
you videos uh I've been you know every
movie is not watch a good movie and
you'll see you're being tricked it's you
got to watch out about being tricked
okay and Magic I like because it's
honest lineing because I'm telling you
I'm tricking you but so videos and
eyewitness evidence is the worst kind of
evidence Unfortunately they use it in
court cases but it's not good evidence
and you have to be skeptical so that
there's been no there's not a single
piece of evidence not one piece of
evidence I repeat that there's not a
single piece of evidence that anything
that we haven't we don't know what we
see and there are lots of things we
don't know what we see there not a
single piece of evidence that the
scientific Community would say is solid
of of anything related to aliens okay
and and that's no matter what people say
there's no evidence about that as far as
the government's handling it I actually
think they're not doing as bad a job now
they're trying to be more open um and I
I watched the press conference from the
NASA uh committee that talked about it
and and and you know they I think they
buried the lead as we used we say in the
newspaper business because they it was
late in the thing where they said
there's no evidence of aliens there was
a long Preamble and most people didn't
get it but you know the idea is to try
and be open about it but the notion of
me to me the most unrealistic thing
about aliens and UFOs is the idea that
our government could have this
incredible conspiracy of secrecy for 60
years I mean come on nothing can be
secret and just think about it if one
person who had knowledge about this
could make a gazillion dollars if they
could speak about it you know when
that's the case there's no way that's
going to remain secret so to me the most
unrealistic thing about all of this UFO
conspiracy is that the government can
keep
secrets yeah I mean I would only add
that you know the two of us up here and
other scientists that are here tonight
are represent incredibly conflicted
people in that there's no one more than
us we scientists who would love nothing
more than to discover the existence of
an advanc civilization who mastered the
laws of time travel of physics and
interplanetary wormholes correlations
whatever and able to to do these Pats of
Technology simply because of the being
old reason that we would get to have
thousands of Nobel prizes that we get to
skip ahead in our understanding of
Science by many centuries and so I kind
of get a little bit annoyed when my my
friends in the UFO Pro Community say
things like oh you're just covering up
or you have a vested interest in us not
being correct and and uh and big
astronomy and I love it if big astronomy
could control anything uh even even you
know uh for for self-interested reasons
so anyway we have a vested interest and
we are saying we haven't seen this we
would like nothing more that it to be
true but as Lawrence's friend Carl Sean
used to say you need to keep an open
mind but not so open that your brains
fall out and you have to hold them to
the same standards uh our friends in the
UFO Community just because you can you
know see things that you you know
eyewitness reports like laurren said
it's really not rising to the level of
data an analysis and so so I I I largely
agree but just to add I would love it to
be true I want to have evidence I I say
I don't want to believe as mhler
Buck malar said we want to believe we
all do want to yeah well and the problem
is most of us do want to believe and
that what scientists have to remind
themselves is that they want to believe
in their own experiments in their own
theories and what what science is good
at at telling us is that recognize that
you want to believe and as Fineman said
the easiest person to to to fool is
yourself because you know what you want
your theory to be right you want your
observation to be right you constantly
have to second guess yourself and that's
really something that's a lesson from
science that that that we really you
know can be so important one last thing
so there are people in science even I've
interviewed them uh Steve Coan was on my
podcast so Lawrence has written a book
Steve Coan WR kind of an opposition book
that you know unsettled science um I
just want to say that all of us agree
even if you're a climate change skeptic
that reducing CO2 and the Comon
pollutants will redown to the benefit of
human health I don't think anybody even
the most Ardent you know opponent of
climate change regulation or technology
will argue against that
but uh just the same way with UFO
technology and supposed technology is I
think it could also benefit Humanity by
making Aerospace safer by by uh having
better communication Freedom of
Information and transparency with the
government I think that's always a good
thing so I think no matter what it's a
net good but but again let's keep our
let's keep scientifically approaching it
and I think that will eventually rown to
the benefit of every and I won't because
of time I won't but if you Carl Sean's
last book a canand signs as a candle in
the dark as a masterpiece and and it's
wonderful to have him read him talk
about UFOs because he points out what a
cultural phenomenon it is people used to
see the same things on years ago and
call them fairies I mean it's a property
of the culture at the time and so why
were UFOs being seen 500 years ago
because they were attributed to
something else so each culture of its
time has their own version of UFOs and
you know just like the fact that most
people who believe in glob happen to
believe that the god that their parents
believe in makes you should make you
suspicious it should all you should also
be suspicious of the fact that that
these things are a property of time and
I'm not I wanted the last question
because I want you to get home to your
kids and it's a simple question what's
your favorite thing or topic to talk or
BS about doesn't have to be science
related and why is it so fascinating or
enjoyable to you uh well living here in
San Diego uh it the thing that I turn to
for
relaxation are the San Diego padr and I
always say easiest job in the world is
to be a meteorologist here in San Diego
this is typical weather for us and the
hardest job is to be a sports kister
because we've never won a single
Championship so for me it's uh it's
relaxation is that I and I I get a lot
of enjoyment sitting on the couch with
my kids and my wife and just watching
the Padres
lose I the rest of us enjoy watching the
padr lose too but but um I think for me
I would say it's movie I like I think we
like I like or you know things I see and
I don't really watch TV so for it's
movies or documentaries but B thing
about movies I like and I I I make some
movies too and so I've always been
fascinated by movies and and I because
they also Inspire the imagination and in
fact as as as Stephen Hawking wrote in
in the forward of the physics of Star
Trek science fiction helps Inspire
imagination and so anything that helps
Inspire imagination excites me and I get
the same excitement from of science
because they both uh they both tickle my
mind thank you very much thank
you